wir starten in den zweiten sommer der
pandemie erleichtert die zahl der
infektionen ist unter die kritische
marke gesunken
warum darüber streiten sich die geister
war es die notbremse war es das impfen
war es die vorsicht der menschen
man muss das genauer wissen wenn man
will dass die zahlen niedrig bleiben und
die politik muss aus den fehlern der
letzten monate lernen rechtzeitig vor
vielleicht einer vierten welle und einer
dritten impfung einen blick zurück ohne
zorn aber mit dem wunsch ist künftig
besser zu machen den wünsche ich mir von
diesen gästen
helge braun der kanzleramtsminister sei
deutschland ist im vergleich mit
europäischen ländern gut durch die
pandemie gekommen
robin alexander der journalist der welt
sagt das land wurde in dieser zeit
schlecht regiert
birgit für die hausärztin ist klar
wegsperren und panik machen war nicht
der richtige weg
karl lauterbach der
spd-gesundheitspolitiker ist sicher der
lockdown hat tausende leben gerettet
jonas schmidt chanasit der virologe sagt
der locker und war nie die einzige
lösung
sie sind zu gast bei maybrit illner und
die begrüßt die gäste diese
ausgesprochen herzlich einen schönen
guten abend los gehts liebe zuschauer
populist bei uns allgemeinmedizinerin
aus hamburg überall frau pohl kehrt
jetzt ein bisschen normalität zurück
außer in den arztpraxen außer in den
hausarztpraxen
wie kommen sie mit diesem ansturm der
leute klar also normalität ist bei uns
ganz sicher nicht der fall und das wird
auch ganze hier lange nicht der fall
sein
wir kommen mit diesem ansturm klar weil
wir damit klarkommen müssen wir haben
gar keine alternative die wird uns von
allen seiten eigentlich auch gar nicht
gelassen aber normalität stelle ich mir
ganz anders vor das ist
patientenversorgung primär und das was
wir jetzt machen ist ein bisschen mühsam
kompensieren dann allen ecken weil wir
uns ob noch ein thema dazu bekommen
haben
auf dass wir nicht wirklich eingerichtet
sind
mit dem impfen und mit gegebenenfalls
auch den engpässen die auszuhalten sind
durch die haus aus praxen wie viele
menschen wie viele patienten warten
jetzt auf eine also wir haben eine liste
der stehen aktuell circa 2.000 patienten
drauf wovon allerdings sehr viele sicher
schon an anderer stelle eine impfung
erhalten haben was auch gut ist
wir beraten eigentlich auch unseren
patienten in die richtung dass sie sich
wirklich auch irgendwie um andere
möglichkeiten kümmern und optionen
aber wenn wir die auch nur im ansatz
durch telefonieren wollen dann würden
wir wenn man es mal konservativ rechnen
mit drei minuten pro gespräch einen arzt
für circa vier wochen binden der von
morgens bis abends versucht die
patienten zu erreichen und
einzubestellen
und das geht nicht das ist nicht unsere
aufgabe deswegen ist das
ein schwieriges unterfangen im moment
und die digitalen info ausweise ganz
ehrlich wenn hier irgendjemand weiß wie
es geht sondern wir es bitte sagen da
waren schon einige patienten heute die
gesagt haben es steht doch in der
zeitung und über all das funktioniert
jetzt tolle sache ja ich finde das auch
eine tolle sache ich wüsste gerne wo ich
meinen hut bekommen
da sieht das generieren kann das kann
keiner meiner kollegen und wir warten
darauf wir haben auch unsere kv täglich
angerufen und gefragt und wie das jetzt
weitergeht oder irgendwie unsere kurz
her bekommen und wie das ganze gehen
soll also die patienten sind da und die
möchten dass und die wedeln mit ihren
impfausweis und ich möchte das gerne
erfüllen
aber es geht nicht keine chance wurde in
ihren augen die priorisierung zu früh
aufgehoben zu spät aufgehoben
ich finde nicht zu früh ich finde das
richtig aus den genannten gründen das
ist administrativ einfach leichter wenn
man sich nicht noch und top um eine
priorisierung kümmern
gleichwohl ist das glaube ich gelebte
praxis in allen praxen das sind ja nicht
nur hausärzte sind ja auch andere
kollegen fachkollegen dass wir natürlich
intern noch priorisieren das ist ja ganz
klar
also wir haben ja von anfang an im blick
wer braucht jetzt die impfung mehr als
andere und das machen wir ganz ohne
anweisungen der tat und das heißt ihre
arbeit in diesem hamburger im zentrum in
dem sie auch dienst geschoben haben ist
vergleichbar mit dem was sie da jetzt zu
leisten haben oder ist es in der praxis
mit ihren drei kollegen ärzte kollegen
sehen das ganz anders
im zentrum ist ein also an ein durchlauf
der ist extrem gut organisiert das ist
sehr gut strukturiert so dass man zu
dienstbeginn mit 50 fremden menschen
anfängt in einem impfpflaster und das
ist derartig standardisiert dass man da
einfach sehr gut rein kommt und dann
läuft das durch und wie impfen wirklich
richtig viel da aber es sind alles
fremde patienten und wir müssen anders
als in anderen ländern unglaublich viel
informationen austauschen und zettel
unterschreiben und durchgehend mit den
patienten neun stück sind das bei uns
und das ist ja viel und das hält aus
sondern auch und das dauert auch und das
ist in der praxis natürlich nicht der
fall weil wir einfach unsere patienten
hier kennen wir müssen da nicht über
andere lesen reden oder allergie oder
vorerkrankungen dass das ist ein
leichter haben das war ja auch immer ein
argument zu sagen
unbedingt soll in den praxen geimpft
werden und nicht nur in den zentren
beides würde hoffentlich weitergeben
können wir auch nie als coo tieren wie
verfahren sie jetzt mit kindern und
jugendlichen das ist ja so nächste bei
der da plötzlich in ihrem feld liegen ja
da kommen viele fragen von den
jugendlichen selber auch für den eltern
ich finde schön dass die jugendlichen
jetzt geimpft werden dürfen wenn sie es
möchten
das muss man wirklich im einzelfall
entscheiden mit kindern erst recht
das muss man sehr genau sich überlegen
aber danach entscheiden so leben sie
überhaupt keine geben ist ist zu wenig
impfstoff ganz genau 3000 leute war ist
es im moment noch eigentlich eine
theorie so wirken der theoretische
erwägung
aber die gespräche führen wir natürlich
schon ganz klar okay
robin alexander ist bei uns journalist
geschätzter kollege von der welt herr
alexander dass jugendliche und ihre
eltern jetzt um diesen knappen impfstoff
weiter konkurrieren ist unschön aber in
so einem wahljahr muss man einfach den
menschen das versprechen das problem war
doch darf dass die ständige
impfkommission also die experten die
darüber entscheiden
gesagt haben sie haben ihre meinung noch
nicht gebildet und gleichzeitig haben
verschiedene kabinettsmitglieder gesagt
doch das müsse jetzt unbedingt kommen
und teilweise auch mit dem argument
gekoppelt man habe den kindern so viel
zugemutet in den jugendlichen deshalb
müssten sie jetzt doch geimpft werden
und das ist eine sachfremde argument da
ist von der regierung einfach verwirrung
gestiftet worden und verwirrung ist
glaube ich das was man angesichts der
allgemeinen kommunikations lage zum
impfen am wenigsten braucht das ist
sicherlich richtig beschrieben erbauen
jens spahn hat so schön gesagt wenn sie
sauer sein wollen dann seien sie sauer
auf mich aber nicht auf die ärzte und
ihre kollegen
ende mai zieht 21 fünfter was haben
frau dr pool und ihre mitarbeiter von so
einem satz der sich ja auch für ein
sparsamer sein soll
im kern sind doch die aufgaben die auch
eben beschrieben worden welche die
pandemie uns aufgibt
wir können sehr froh seien dass wir
jetzt einen impfstoff haben und an
diesem zweiten quartal auch schon viel
mehr als im ersten
in den ersten drei monaten nur acht
millionen menschen impfen können
jetzt haben wir die impfzentren laufen
sozusagen auf halber kapazität und die
hausarztpraxen haben auch endlich
impfstoffmengen die relevant sind und
dieses thema muss man sich überlegen
haben die hausärzte jetzt nicht mehr
genügend kapazität für die eigentliche
patientenversorgung und könnte auch
durchaus die im zentrum noch mal ein
bisschen hoch fahren aber das ist ein
sozusagen eine entscheidung die es nicht
leicht weil auf der anderen seite ist ja
auch im patientenstamm jedes einzelnen
hausarzt dessen hoher erwartung dass man
sich über hausarzt impfen dass die
patienten das auch sehr viel liebe wir
greifen das argument von robin alexander
auf es ist erstens zu wenig impfstoff da
und zweitens ist völlig verwirrend warum
die berater die gestern noch
entscheidend waren für die regierung
heute nicht mehr entscheidend sind mit
ihrem votum dass man kinder und
jugendliche nicht unbedingt aufnehmen
sollte in diesen kann also wir haben
jetzt uns eigentlich sehr genau nach dem
gerichtet was die stiko heute auch
entschieden hat wir haben selbst gesagt
es gibt nur eine impfempfehlung für vor
erkannte kinder jugendliche die sollten
sich impfen lassen weil sie an einem
risiko haben und für alle anderen bin
ich aber auch sehr froh dass hat die
stiko heute auch gesagt soll es nach dem
individuellen arztgespräch in
einvernehmen mit den mit den eltern und
den kindern und den jugendlichen auch
die möglichkeit geben was wir nicht
machen wollen ist jetzt zwölf bis 15
jährigen sagen es gibt zwar einen
zugelassenen impfstoff für euch wir
dürften nicht kriegen sondern da muss
man sehr deutlich sagen das hat die
stiko heute sehr präzise auch
wissenschaftlich belegt dass es noch
relativ wenig daten gibt dass es aber
einen zugelassenen impfstoff gibt und
dass das deshalb auch nach dem
individuellen risiko empfinden dann
zwischen
dem dem beratenden hausarzt und den kind
und jugendlichen entschieden werden kann
ob man sich impfen lässt und wir kriegen
wir in den nächsten wochen auch immer
mehr daten wenn man mal sieht den usa
sind jetzt schon 3,5 millionen in dieser
altersgruppe gelähmt war also was die
sicherheit angeht gewinnen wir jetzt
auch immer mehr grund wir sind bei den
wissenschaftlern und fragen zunächst
jonas schmidt chanasit
eine ähnliche frage bisher hieß es immer
man hält sich an die empfehlung der
entscheidenden berater in dieser
pandemie und jetzt sagt die stiko das
ist nicht zwingend für alle jugendlichen
in diesem alter eine ausgesprochene
impfempfehlung gibt sondern sie machen
diese einlassung und zum anderen wurden
auch und abstände verkürzt verstehen sie
die logik dahinter
also ich dir vollkommen der
entscheidungen der stiko ist ja eine der
wenigen unabhängigen institution die
eben evidenzbasiert zu diesen
entscheidungen kommt und ich hätte mir
wenn man es auch schon diskutiert
wirklich gewünscht dass im vorfeld
dieser entscheidung die kakophonie der
meinung nicht so stark durchschlägt weil
das eben genau zu letztendlich
verunsicherung führt wir haben in
anderen bereichen eben nicht so ein
unabhängiges expertengremium leider was
die pandemie betrifft und insofern hat
die stiko auch ganz klar gesagt und die
entscheidenden drei absätze sind am ende
der stellungnahme dass es eine
momentaufnahme ist die daten werden
jetzt zusätzlich eben generiert auch in
anderen ländern und dann kann man diese
entscheidung natürlich anpassen das ist
ein vollkommen richtiges vorgehen
man muss da eben sehr sehr sorgfältig
umgehen mit dieser entscheidung eben
auch weil es letztendlich vielleicht
mögliche langzeitschäden betrifft
insofern ist es ganz ganz wichtig das
berücksichtigen war ja einen grundsatz
ist des ärztlichen handelns dass wir ja
eben erst mal zunächst nicht schaden
sollen nicht also das ist ganz ganz
wichtig und uns sehr gut die maßnahmen
überlegen in bezug auf eine mögliche
erkrankung und es steht auch ganz klar
drin im absatz dass eben diese impfung
auf keinen fall eine bedingung sein kann
für schulbesuch
das hatte ich mir auch schon kritisch
gesagt sie hatten dass er auch
formuliert dass für einen regelbetrieb
es notwendig sein könnte diese impfungen
durchzuführen oder das ist nicht mit dem
nicht für die teilnahme der kinder ich
musste vorher widersprechen
meine position war ich ja etwas ab von
der position von ein spezielles it und
auch das haben sie jetzt schon mal sehr
freundlich an moderiert und wir wären
natürlich auch die frage halten sie es
denn für zu gefährlich wenn man jetzt
die kinder in die schule lässt und alles
wieder eröffnet
ohne dass die kinder logischerweise alle
games sehen nein das halte ich nicht für
zu gefährlich
aber zunächst also eine
wissenschaftliche frage wie man jetzt
mit der situation umgeht da kann man
unterschiedlich also gewichten
unterschiedlich rauskommt die stiko
stellt ja in den vordergrund dass man
die langfristigen schäden erst
kennenlernen muss erst dann könne man
kindern die impfung empfehlen
aber das würde bedeuten dass wir für
eine lange zeit kindern die impfung
nicht empfehlen können weil diese
langfristigen schäden die werde ich auch
nicht in zwei monaten kennen sondern wie
sich meinetwegen in einem jahr oder in
anderthalb jahren und somit wenn man das
zu ende denkt wird es mit der empfehlung
der stiko auf absehbarer zeit
wahrscheinlich für das ganze jahr in
deutschland keine impfung geben
das halte ich aus drei gründen für
falsch weiß reichen zwei wenn umwelt
schneller sprechen da hab ich dann
bringe ich beschleunige ich beschleunige
den rhythmus der ersten runde schlicht
ergreifend da ist die wahrscheinlichkeit
dass man eine späte reaktion späten an
experten im schaden sieht und nicht denn
im schaden früh sieht er ist bei
impfungen allgemein also selten punkt
allgemein sind und bei dieser art
impfung ist rechts hätten somit also die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass wir in
anderthalb jahren an später neben
schaden sehen die man am anfang nach 10
von nicht gesehen hat diese
wahrscheinlichkeit ist auf der grundlage
von spezialisten die haben oft
beispielsweise einer führenden maxim
logan welt war sehr gering somit was wir
jetzt nicht sehen das werden wir auch
später wahrscheinlich nicht
der zweite grund ist in ändern zum
beispiel ähnliche variante kranken auch
kinder und die kinder erkranken so dass
ein prozent der kinder die sich
infizieren und erkrankten ins
krankenhaus müssen somit das keine
kleinigkeit
und das ist etwas was die kinder auch
schädigen kann
und das kann auch bei einem teil der
kinder zu longo fit für und somit werden
kann also situation hier wo man sagen
kann die kinder brauchen das nicht
sondern die brauchen die kinder
profitieren auch und zum dritten
ich glaube tatsächlich wir werden die
schule wieder anschalten wieder anlaufen
lassen so wie wir sie im anlaufen lassen
quasi mit normalem regelbetrieb aber
dann werden wir hat sehr viele
infektionen bei den kindern sehen und
ich finde es also nicht richtig dass wir
sagen bei den erwachsenen also schützen
wir durch den impfung und die bei den
kindern schützen wir in dem die sich
infiziert und darauf würde das nämlich
im großen und ganzen hinauslaufen daher
komme ich einfach inhaltlich da anders
heraus aber ich räume ein das ist eine
position die man nicht teilen muss das
ist die position die die amerikanischen
wissenschaftler getragen haben also die
kollegen zum beispiel von der
harvard-universität die also die
amerikanische regierung auch mit beraten
haben die kommen raus die empfehlen die
info man kann das auch anders sehen aber
es ist nicht so dass man sagen kann und
man muss es so sehen wir dich steht
sodann sind wir noch mal bei robin
alexander und der politischen
einschätzungen alexander nochmal
dieselbe frage
bisher war es immer entscheidend den
beratern und ihren ihrem votum zu folgen
egal ob es um die stiko oder um diego
ging
und plötzlich sind diese dinge
relativiert und sie werden anders
entschieden es werden im abstände
verkürzt und es sind tatsächlich eben
auch nun kinder und jugendliche
aufgefordert sich impfen zu lassen
obwohl kein impfstoff da ist was macht
man damit was ist das für eine logik
naja das kann das kann impfstoff da es
ist ja verantwortung der politik und
nicht der verantwortung der experten
aber ich finde in lauterbachs position
plausibel weil wir haben doch jetzt alle
mit unseren kindern im lockdown gesessen
und wir haben den kindern erzählt wir
können erst wieder raus wenn wir gut
sind und wenn ihr nicht geimpft sein
habt ihr nicht nur ein persönliches
risiko sondern ihr habt auch das risiko
die infektion weiter zu tragen an die
großeltern oder an ältere leute die in
der kirchengemeinde oder sonstwo trifft
und jetzt den gleichen kindern nach
diesen ganzen zeit im lok down zu
erklären
ihr kriegt die impfung mich also das
finde ich relativ schwierig zu erklären
und damit sind wir wieder bei frau pohl
die kinder können erkranken sie können
auch an longo wird erkranken
darauf macht nicht nur karl lauterbach
aufmerksam aber sie haben auch extrem
unter diesem jahr unter diesen 15
monaten corona gelitten
wie fällt ihre abweg router aus wie
würden sie bilanz ziehen also die
abwägung der jugendlichen von denen kann
ich eigentlich eher sprechen weil ich
bin keine kinderärztin bei uns sind die
hände genommen ab 15 16 genau da wollen
sie sich mit kinder genannt werden
stimmt die fällt ganz klar für die
meisten pro impfungen weil sie
realisieren dass sie ihre freiheit nur
so wieder kriegen im moment die haben
gar nicht angst vor kitsch sondern die
wollen einfach wieder tun was sie eben
tun möchten in diesem alter dass wir die
schulen immer wieder aufmachen also nun
waren sie gerade mal sechs monate zu und
dass wir sie immer wieder aufmachen habe
ich so nicht erlebt ich habe auch noch
ein schulpflichtiges kind und diesen
betrieb wechsel unterricht gehen möchte
man eigentlich nicht wirklich
unterrichten
das ist eigentlich eine einzige
katastrophe und ehrlich gesagt verstehe
ich auch nicht genau warum sich die
parameter schon wieder geändert haben am
anfang habe ich das verstanden da waren
lehrkräfte die waren nicht geschützt und
die sind ängstlich gewesen und auch zu
recht weil die im risiko standen bei den
kindern ja die können auch erkranken
aber sicher immer noch nicht so schwer
wie eben ältere wohl nahe gruppen und
wenn jetzt doch die lehrer so nach und
nach und die mitarbeiter der schulen
geimpft sind dann glaube ich
dürfen wir nie wieder die kinder nicht
in die schule lassen denn die wie ein
risiko haben
die sind jetzt geschützt und ob die
kinder im einzelnen durch eine
asthmatische vorerkrankung adipositas
irgendwas geimpft werden möchten werden
die kinder mit den eltern entscheiden
deswegen finde ich es auch richtig dass
sie geimpft werden dürfen
aber unter gar keinen umständen müssen
dann unter gar keinen umständen dass man
wieder die schulen zu machen so da nicht
sogar herr lauterbach und wir fragen uns
noch mal herr schmidt chanasit um das
ein wenig abzurunden ob man tatsächlich
eben den kindern den lehrkräften den
eltern jetzt in die diese beruhigung
geben kann dass sie nicht mit einer
weiteren infektionen in der schule zu
rechnen haben oder wie gehen eltern
heute in die schule und schicken ihre
kinder in die schule in mit welchem
gefühl ist es weiter ein gefühl der
unsicherheit oder eines der sicherheit
da gibt es auch entsprechende leitlinien
die jenseits der impfungen entwickelt
wurden um eben den schulbetrieb
sicherzustellen das geht eben über
lüften masten usw
man muss schon sehen dass wir eine
andere situation haben werden im herbst
werden sich hoffentlich das hoffe ich
sehr sehr sehr viele erwachsene neben
impfen lassen das hat natürlich auch
einen einfluss auf die infektion in der
kinder das leben einer anderen ländern
die schon weiter mit den impfungen sind
und ich teile mich auch nochmal ganz
klar sagen nicht die einschätzung von
karl lauterbach dass das medizinisch ein
großes problem wäre ich und das sage
nicht ich sondern in rücksprache mit den
pädiatern die eben natürlich genau diese
daten auch zu sammeln
bezüglich longo wird und eben schweren
erkrankungen also teams sind das
wirklich sehr sehr wenige fälle in
deutschland
das kann in anderen ländern vielleicht
etwas anders aussehen aber da bin ich ja
auch mal sehr vorsichtig mit diesen
ländern vergleichen und wenn wir studien
aus diesen ländern nehmen dass wir das
eins zu eins auf unsere situation in
deutschland übertragen aber wir können
uns jetzt streiten ob das einst von 100
oder 1 von 1000 sind die ins krankenhaus
aufgenommen werden das was ich
zumindestens von denen kinder ärzten
höre ist dass die meisten fälle gut
behandelbar sind und bei den teams
fehlen wo wir 235 nur registriert haben
in der daten mannes kennen sie ja
sind es zehn prozent davon also knapp 30
litern spätfolgen haben sich einen satz
dagegen halten
es ist richtig die teams also
komplikation ist sehr selten aber dass
die diese gespräche haben meistens die
folgende also figur dass wir in
deutschland also sagen mal von berichten
hören da der und er hat gesagt oder der
und der pädiater sieht oder die und die
gruppe also berichtet das sehe ich nicht
oft und zuleitung spot und auf der
anderen seite stehen aber ausgewertete
und in erstklassigen journalen
publizierte studien die auf der
grundlage einer statistischen erhebung
zustande gekommen sind
das heißt ich muss auch jetzt trotzdem
so vorgehen was wir immer machen
eine studie die peer review publiziert
worden ist die nach kriterien der
evidenzbasierten medizin nicht zustande
gekommen ist
selbst wenn die aus dem ausland kommt
die gewichte ich höher als dass ich hier
mit einem pda ton gesprochen haben die
haben ja was erzählt dann sind ist
einfach und das muss aber ehrlicherweise
sagt ja ich wünschte übrigens wer also
ich hoffe dass da so diese ähnliche
variante nicht so gefährlich ist für
kinder wie wir jetzt hören
england wird eben berichtet ein prozent
der betroffenen kinder los ins
krankenhaus
wenn sich das nicht zeigen würde bin ich
der erste der sich darüber freut ich
habe auch an der tochter
das ist für uns vollkommen eigentlich
sozusagen die datenerhebung des
katastrophe dass ich glaube dass wir uns
vollkommen einig da sind uns andere
länder großbritannien war vorbildlich
wir haben es nicht geschafft nationale
kohorte früh einzubinden zu nutzen um
auch eine bessere bewertung der pandemie
situation zu erreichen männer nach wie
vor in dieser instanz ja immer weniger
an bedeutung natürlich hat je mehr wir
müssen also und das wäre wichtig auch
eben gerade im bereich der schulen oder
kinder und damit merken sie liebe
zuschauer wir sind nicht nur in einem
streit der wissenschaft sondern wollten
in dieser sendung auch mal versuchen auf
diese letzten 15 monate zu schauen und
fragen was können wir lernen aus dem was
in dieser zeit geschehen ist die zahlen
gehen runter manche sagen das ist den
maßnahmen der pandemie zu danken die
zahlen
runter und andere sagen das hat genau
damit zu tun dass diese maßnahmen
übertrieben waren
nach 15 monaten haben wir so ziemlich
alles durch lotta und varianten mit
tollen namen großen erwartungen und
zweifelhaften resultat
was haben locker uns gebracht wie
gefährlich waren lockerungen gab es
alternativen
[Musik]
es gibt zum beispiel eine ganz
interessante studie die auch kollegen
lauterbach kennen wenn man eben sehr
sehr oft testet dass man letztendlich
auf alle regeln nahezu verzichten kann
und eben regelmäßig getestet wird aber
dazu braucht es letztendlich testen die
breit verfügbar sind die sehr preiswert
sind und die eben auch sehr häufig
eingesetzt werden als im herbst die
zweite welle rollt streit um die
richtung glaubenskrieg zwischen corona
falken und tauben werden bei schatton
leute dem prinzip dass man die an fluten
de zweite welle
also dieses exponentielle wachstum dass
man das noch bricht so lange wie es geht
das ist eine lehrbuch ähnlich sein mal
unterbrechung des zwar hat der zweiten
welle ein kurzer sprint von vier wochen
kann vielleicht dazu führen dass sich
die situation lockert aber dann sind wir
weihnachten wieder an einem ähnlichen
punkt und müssen wir uns wieder etwas
überlegt
heute wissen wir der wellenbrecher war
gar keine sondern lediglich der
startschuss für sieben monate lockdown
gekrönt durch eine bundes notbremse die
fast alle ministerpräsidenten ratlos
zurücklässt
dass wir im übrigen keinen rechten
fortschritt erkennen können für den
infektionsschutz und für mein land
gelange ich zu der kurz bewertung
unnötig zur bundes notbremse kommen wir
noch robin alexander teil shutdown
wellenbrecher brücken lockdown es waren
tatsächlich immer wieder interessante
formulierungen für ein und dasselbe
prinzip nämlich bleibt zuhause dicht
machen hat die politik keine alternative
das dichtmachen war richtig vor allem
den ganz am anfang haben ja auch alle
leute mit getragen ist ja nicht so dass
das gegen die bevölkerung gemacht wurde
die leute waren ja dafür und so recht
nur dann ist ja relativ wenig lange
passiert wir haben ein sommer erlebt wo
wir aus dem sommer kam und in den
schulen gab es überhaupt keine
veränderte situation
wir haben erlebt dass das impfen spielt
anfängt das testen fing bei uns später
an also unsere unser start war sehr gut
darin die leute zu ermahnen zuhause zu
bleiben und sehr gut darin ihn geld zu
versprechen beides war auch nicht falsch
aber anderes was staat leisten muss
das hat nicht so gut funktioniert